thanks for intruction so this is um
something that I have worked on for
probably for at least 2.5 years you know
maybe even more than five years so I
still remember that uh like in 2022
Europe I think I spent like before that
I spent probably louder please okay um
the mic is not working or okay okay I
I'm not loud enough okay that's um yeah
so this is um a project that I I spent
probably two years 2.5 years at least
two to work on um yeah I think I I
remember there's a few deadlines before
the deadlines we spend like probably a
whole week you know from from 10 to 10:
a.m. to 10 p.m. and and I didn't work
out and that uh that happened for two or
three that eventually uh this year we
work it out um you know but you know
don't have to have of expectation either
because this is really hard like
optimizing your works is really hard so
we we only have a very simple case that
we can work out so um yeah so I guess
let me start with a little bit more kind
of like a um uh high level overview of
this area about optimizing neww works so
um I've been working on this like for a
long time and I think everyone know that
this is non-convex and and that means
it's MP hard in the worst case so um but
in in practice SD item works pretty well
in practice so the question is you know
why this works and certainly the the um
um I think what um because em SGD works
very well in practice it means that the
landscape is not going to be terrible
right it's not going to be crazy like
this so um so so there are several ideas
to kind of like analyze uh why um in
practice SGD can work so one of the idea
is that all local minimum approximately
Global minimum so um and there are a lot
of cases that people have be able to uh
have been able to prove uh this is the
case so uh and most of these cases are
linear algebra cases where you have some
kind of Matrix factorization um Matrix
factorization Matrix completion you know
linear R NW Works where you don't have
any activations or you have a deep
linear R NW works with some residual
connections so on so forth and the
common techniques is linear algebra and
uh and it sounds like people use a lot
of like at least in these papers I said
it that linear algebra techniques are
heavily used and uh it's very hard to
extend to
nonlinearity um and um so and a reason
seems to be that you have a you don't
have enough tools to reason about this
set of local minimum which is basically
a set of um solutions to um to the the
Gent is equal to zero equation and you
add additional constraint that has is
larer than zero so uh I add this I added
this L just for my own kind of like
personal kind of like uh um um kind of
like Obsession in some sense because uh
I I was thinking about this for a long
time and these are the two ideas that I
always thought that there's still a
chance but but I couldn't work it out uh
and I for me it's kind of like like I
already give up but uh but I want to
kind of bring brought them up just uh so
that maybe more people can can think
about it so uh so one idea is that you
know if all of these things are
polinomial then you can use algebra
geometry to study the this this thing
right the the solutions of some system
of equations that sounds like what
algebraic geometries uh can can can do
but the problem seems to be that first
of all um algebra geometry doesn't
really give you automatic solution
understanding of about like a any
polinomial system equations you know you
do need to work out um some uh some
details and another thing is it's very
hard to deal with this second constraint
where the hashing is PSD uh it sounds
like you need some kind of like a
positive like a positive Al geob
algebraic geometry which I don't really
know that much so um yeah and another
possibility is that I can think of is
that you can use ciz formula so where
you um you count uh the number of
solutions to some set of equations um
and you you leverage the fact that L is
a is random and then you can do some
counting stuff um and I I had a paper on
this um for some T de composition
problem and it it took like like 40
pages to uh to to to compute this C
formula and uh and we only kind of like
did a partial case and it it turns out
that the issue is that it's very hard to
um uh um calculate the expectation of
this uh determinant of the hen which
shows up in the the cast R formula um at
least I don't know how to do it um so
yeah so I guess um um but uh um but a
little more kind of like a um taking a
little higher level kind of perspective
it seems to me that um now like these
days I I feel that maybe the fundamental
challenge is not necessarily only on the
technical level but also on the level
that actually maybe not it's not true
that all local minim are Global uh and
it's probably far from uh you know I
never thought that this is exactly true
you know even from day one but I always
thought that it's kind of close enough
to be true but now I I I feel that maybe
um it's far away from true in some sense
uh so that um so that probably it's not
necessary like the right statement to
prove at least you probably should allow
the techniques to should allow some
small number of Bal minimum in some way
um and and you say that you never reach
those B
minimal
so I'm a little confused are you
conjecturing that uh that these uh these
methods achieve a near Global Optima
because the models work so well and is
it possible that there's another reason
that they work well uh that that even
with as you say bad local Minima oh I
see so yeah so the question is that
whether we even know that this methods
reach a local a global minimum or
approximate Global minimum I think that
um that's of course a conjecture but um
uh it's not too crazy of a conjunction
because um the loss is very small the
you know that the loss can never go
below zero and you see that empirically
the loss go to at least foration tasks
but the loss is very small so so so so
it's not that crazy to conjecture that
you converge to approximate Global
minimum uh for language Tas it becomes a
little tricky because you know like the
the the law cannot be zero right there's
there's a minimal entropy for the for
the large language models and and I I've
seen that number goes down like we don't
know what the entropy of the English is
yet so so and that number becomes now
point1 1.1 1.2 so even something like
that so so I don't know whether it's a
local it's a global minimum but it still
sounds reasonable to believe that you
converge to a pretty good Global minimum
um okay um yeah so so but um yeah so
basically what I believe is that there
are uh so you are converging we are
converging to a good uh we are
converging to a global minimum but maybe
they are still bad local minimum
somewhere else uh that you never reach
to um okay so and there's another idea
which is kind of like a little bit
related to this the last line where you
allow some outliers right so in some
sense the other idea the neurot tangent
kernel approach is that you uh you look
at specific regions you don't care about
the global landscape you say I only care
about the special region where I start
uh um close to my starting point my
starting point is some kind of like a
randomization with per particular scale
and then you identify a region which is
often kind of like a ball and you say in
this region the loss is actually convex
or approximately convex and there exists
a global minimum in this region and then
you say um when you optimize in this
region you converge to that Global
minimum and uh and optimizing in this
region is equivalent to doing a kernel
method with NE tangent kernel with the
So-Cal NE tangent kernel which I I don't
think we have to Define for this talk um
and this seems to be very powerful
because you can apply this to various
settings in deep learning almost all
settings like even adversary examples
you large anguish model maybe deep
reinforcement so on and so forth um but
the problem is that it turns out that in
reality the SD doesn't necessarily
operate in this region uh um because
people are choosing different hyper
parameters so you have to choose the
right hyper parameters for nalization
and the and the with and so forth to get
into this region but in reality the
Practical algorithms don't operate in
this region and as a result if you
operate in this region you don't have
good test error you don't have good
tuning error but you don't have very
good test
error so um and in reality is something
like um like this maybe somewhere else
um so the third idea is the mean field
analysis so um so the idea is that you
analyze the Dynamics of each rates uh uh
as opposed to the landscape so you you
you forget about what's the global
landscape the the loss function look
like you just care about how the the
itas moves uh uh based on the Dynamics
and um and also U more importantly I
think you approximate the Dynamics of a
finan w networks biod dynamics of
infinite W networks um so um I have more
details later but that's the the main
point so and and the problem is that if
you have uh even the Dynamics of INF n
work is still highly non tribute you
have some tools to analyze it but it's
still very non-trivial and also the
approximation error between the infinite
WTH and Final weth networks uh could go
grow up you know exponentially fast and
uh and and so so how do you really do
this approximation becomes
tricky um and there are some of the
existing results along this line that
analyze um on the new works and give you
endtoend polinomial time results with
modified SGD so basically what this
means is that you first train the first
layer with very small ination uh to to
get good features uh and then you CH the
second layer to get the coefficients uh
on top of the features and this is kind
of like a two-stage algorithm where you
in the middle you change the uh your
algorithm even though you are both in
both two stage you are using some op SD
type of algorithms but you are not
optimizing the same set of variables you
are not using the same learning rate
it's a it's a abrupt changes um and um
and there are many other works that kind
of modify SD in a similar way to get a
two-stage algorithm and then you can uh
have this kind of like a um um uh
feature learning uh step first and then
you learn the coefficients on top of the
features but in practice with people
this kind of algorithms don't really
work and uh um and you don't have to use
this kind of like two-stage algorithm
you just do uh the same mutualization
maybe you have some learning rate WM
schedule but um but a relatively simple
algorithm okay so basically it was the
open question U to analyze the
optimization of two layer networks um
Beyond quadratic and linear and
quadratic activations with a sample
complex is strictly better than ntk uh
without modifying that GD and GD and
with polinomial w and polinomial time so
yeah it's it's the end of all of this
not all yeah so uh it's an open question
to achieve all of this um and and this
paper basically give you um analysis
that satisfies the criteria above we use
uh quartic uh Target functions and
activations so that you cannot uh uh
just only leverage linear algebra um and
you have a better sample complex than
ntk so so you get the sample complexity
guarantee um and you don't have to
modify the GR in descent and you also
have polom ways and polinomial number of
iterations so it's a fully polinomial
time
algorithm okay so here's the setting so
um um so you have a with M newwork uh of
this form so you have UI transpose X
that's the first layer UI is the weight
of the first layer um and you have I of
these weight vectors and you you have a
activation function called Sigma and
then you add up all of the neurons Sigma
UI transpose X and you average by one
over you divide by one over M so
basically this means that the second
layer are being uh all one over M so you
are just you don't you don't see the
second layer it's just really just the
the second layer is just all the ways
are one over M and not trint and here we
have some kind of like a normalization
so UI and X are both um un norm and
that's for for some um mathematical
convenience um and we are using this
kind of mfield approach
um at least on the conceptual level so
um and um so and the me field approach
the main idea is that you rewrite this
new NW workk uh in this form um so and
you you view it as infinite waste
networks in some sense so basically if
you have infinite waste networks what
you do is you say you have a family of
use and this use forms a distribution
and then uh this you write the the sum
as expectation over the distribution of
use so in some sense you can view the
finite was n work as infinite was NW
workk by saying that my distribution Ro
is really just a a discrete distribution
supported on U1 up to U and this is a
uniform distribution supported on U up
to so basically if you choose Ro to be
this and then these two equations are
the
same and uh and the width on the other
hand is the the the size of the support
of Y so so this is a way to kind of like
a um um um this so so basically now you
have a way to describe both infinite
wasting n work and final wasting NW work
if uh U the W is finite then that means
row is a discrete distribution if the if
row is a continuous distribution for
example if row is just culion then you
have infinite W work you have basically
you are sampling from Gan distribution
for the for the weight so so this is a
little bit nicer language to some extent
um so that you can unify these two cases
um and we have quarted polinomial
activations Sigma with a non-trivial
degree four term uh for example the kind
of the design choice we have is that we
want Sigma to be able to um we want
Sigma can be equal to uh the degree for
approximation of Ru under some basis so
so so so so I'm not going to talk about
details here but basically you can
allow um quite kind of like a number of
possible degree for polinomial including
the degree for approximation of the
value okay so U and Target function is
this So-Cal single index model um so
basically you have a single Direction
que and you project your data into the
Direction q and then you have unknown
function h on top of it so H is unknown
qu quic sorry qute polinomial that can
be non monotone and Q is unknown
Direction and this is a very common um U
test badge these days for studying two
layer networks and one of the reason is
that of course it's nonlinear that's
good and also one of the reason is that
for this uh kind of Target functions you
can see this so-called kernel and the
statistical limit Gap um in the sense
that you know that there's a lower bound
or or imp possibility results for using
kernel approach so if you use ink or use
any kernel approach that is generic U
then it requires D to the four samples
to learn this model U and and and four
means comes from the the cortic
polinomial and and statistically I think
very likely you should just only need
the samples because you have you only
need you only have the uh fre parameters
that's the dimension of Q um and in the
more extreme case if Q is known if you
really know Q then actually you just
need a probably constant number of
samples because what you do is you say
I'm going to create a a new feature map
which just Maps my X to Q trans x q
transpose x square Q transpose X Cube so
that I have the uh the right set of
features this is very informative
features and then you just have to learn
the H uh which just requires probably
five parameters so you need only all of
One samples to to learn this once you
have got the right features so basically
this is saying that if you don't have
the right features you just use a
generic feature for example ntk or any
other generic features in a product
feature for example and then you need D
to the for samples but in the extreme
case if you know the queue then you you
you have all five samples and what
happens what should be the case is
something in the Middle where you don't
know the queue and you learn a queue and
and after learn a queue get the right
features and then you spend probably all
F samples to uh to to solve the problem
um and and in some sense this is also
give you the nice kind of conceptual um
uh understanding that
um neww Works can go beyond just the
generic kernel because neww Works allows
you to learn a good kernel um so that
you have better sample
complexity um yeah so that's uh why we
work with this um and just a very quick
kind of like background on the pr
settings here so um so if you uh in the
most trivial case suppose Sigma and H
are the same then you have um uh
expressivity and you can you can can see
TR you have expressivity because you
just have to choose row to be a point
mass and U to be equal to q and then
these two functions are the same so
that's the the most trival case but this
is not the case we're going to work on
we are going to work on the cases where
Sigma can be different from H and in
those cases the the expressivity is a
non tribute and and what happens here is
that because the target function only
has one direction which is special which
is Q so the optimal way to fix the
target function with these two lay
Network is to choose your U to be
symmetric around Q so you shouldn't do
anything special in any other directions
the only thing you do is that you choose
some distribution of U that is symmetric
around Q um and and you know that you
know if you choose U to be like that
then you average out over U here then
you are going to have a function that is
only a function of Q transpose X and the
distribution of the um I'm distribution
of Q transpose you basically the only
thing that matters is that projection of
everything to the direction of Q right
so so that's the optimal way to fit this
kind of like model so the optimal
solution should be a symmetric function
uh the the optimal new works uh should
give should have a should be a symmetric
distribution uh um around WR Direction
q and and you can actually do this you
know you a very precise way you can get
give the almost kind of like a
sufficient and necessary conditions on
when such a expressivity can happen the
condition is kind of like a tri state so
that's why I omited but um but but you
can characterize that almost exactly and
our results applies to basically all the
cases where you have expressivity except
a small subset of corner cases um okay
and under this setting what we can prove
is that um so if you use um Greening
flow on the uh actually project ging
flow because you have uninorm
constraints you do projection on the
uninorm and if you use loss function
which is just a standard empirical mean
Square loss uh and you use polinomial
way much works and you use D to the 3.1
samples then you can achieve a little of
one population loss and and the same
setting if you use a uh kernel method
with in any in prodct kernel it requires
D to the four samples to achieve the
same
error um yeah so the rest of the time
will be um about how do we uh prove this
uh and the plan to prove this is that
you um you go through this kind of
meanfield analysis so you first analyze
the training Dynamics for infinite with
infinite sample case and then you
compare the Dynamics of the infinite WS
the you compare dynamics of the final ws
and final sample case with the Dynamics
of infinite weight uh infin with an
infinite sample case so so this is kind
of like a some kind of
approximation um kind of like peration
kind of like Theory kind of stuff and
this is about the population case can I
ask
if sorry thank you if if uh Sigma and H
are say equal and value I know you're
not exactly doing value but like is is
this a convex objective or
no like the loss ultimately as a
function of the
weights if Sigma and H are
both um I don't think so I think if you
only have one U it will be um I think
that's a that's so suppose your system
only you only allow one with one so then
it's going to be a not convex but costy
convex uh um uh and also that requires
you to
know okay so because you already know so
because you in that case you know the H
right so Sigma is equal to H you you
know you know the H and basically if you
know the H and if H is monotone and you
only have one weight Vector then uh I
think uh KKK ask uh K like uh
2011 um so so there's a paper that shows
that that's a costy convex situation
which means Cy conx means that the
gradient is always larger than the loss
function um and then you can prove the
the
conver um yeah but once you have like
multiple use it becomes tricky because
it can be actually once you have so this
is an interesting thing so once you have
a um a system with um permutation in
then there's no way it's convex anymore
because uh you can always permute two
different use in like you you swap to
use um and it's the same um uh it's the
same uh system right so under those
cases I think you can actually um jungo
has a blog post uh that proves that um
any know these cases you must have
station reports um and it's a pretty
generic proof like you even need to it's
not doesn't have to be a new
networ
yeah can can you explain a bit this
order one population error like uh why
why this is good thing and how does this
compare with like your initial like
initial error oh the initial ER yeah so
so the initial error is on the order of
one so it's really just absolute
constant like at least in the um yeah I
I I I omit some of the details here but
in the under the setting that we can
prove formula the uh the initial error
is on the out of one maybe a constant
half
and and that's why achieving something
less than one means you learn something
okay um so the um the optimization
problem class is that still an NP hard
problem class in terms of complexity and
um does your theory say anything about
so so you're saying something about the
sample complexity is the computational
complexity still potentially
exponentially large oh the the run time
is still like a
is is polinomial because um because you
have polinomial number of iterations
polinomial everything is polinomial so
the the the rant is polinomial um um but
I don't think you can talk about NP
hardness here because you have only one
target uh basically you only have one
loss function right when you have NP to
talk about NP hardness you have to have
a f of problems so right now you only
have you know you still have a family of
problems to some extent but the H
function can be is a can can vary right
the the H function the H function can
vary and the Q can vary
right yeah so so then this is not heart
and this for this F
functions um yeah so so I'm going to
start with the the the onedimensional
case and then sorry the the infinite
with infinite sample case and then I'm
going to talk about approximation so uh
let me just remind you the the notation
I'm going to use so I'm going to use the
the right hand side as the my notation
for Works um and once you have this
notation the population LW on the in the
left hand side it's going to be y minus
the the N square and on the right hand
side we're going to rest write Yus F RX
squ and row is this um basically
captures the distribution of U and then
you can compute the gradient uh for both
of these cases you know the exact
details don't really matter so but you
can compute a gradient with respect to
each of the particles on youu uh and you
can get the the how does U moves over
over time so basically the way that I
think about this is that U is kind of
like the particle and row is the
distribution of the particle um so so
and and row is merely just a a way to to
name the particle you don't really
actually in this whole talk we are not
going to compute the density of row so
so row is just there just to say this is
a collection of particles um okay so um
so basically you um each of the particle
U moves according to this rule um and
this rule depends on two things one
thing depends on where you at right so
which V which um particle you are
talking about and the other things
depends on the row the distribution of
the particles so that's the how does
this work so at any time this is a
vector field because the row is fixed
and then you you just at every point you
have a vector field and and what happens
is kind of like uh this is still setting
up the language in some sense the way we
think about this is the following so at
the beginning you have a bunch of like a
particles right which is forms probably
uniform distribution over the sphere
that's because that's how you uh
initialize and then the uh the turns out
that the way to think about this is
probably the best way to think about is
that you think of like um every neuron
every Point have a so like there's a
starting point right so you say Kai is
the starting point uh uh um which is the
neuron uh in the initial situation and
then you you can track you know how does
this point moves right so you can say uh
U UT UT Kai is the uh is where this
point moves toward at time T so and you
call that UT Kai and it's the location
of Kai at time T and and you can write
this Dynamics and then you can say um
because you have so many points that are
all moving together and at every time
you can Define row T to be the
distribution of all the
points the locations of those points at
those time so so so this is the picture
I guess the the notation is a little
complicated but basically this is what
we're talking about okay so so basically
you're checking all of the how all of
these points are moving um but know that
each How does each point move depends on
the collection of all the other points
because uh the the Dynamics depends on
Ro the distribution uh at at that time
but but the but How does each point
moves don't depend on individual other
points it depends only on the collection
the the the the the the collective
behavior of all the other
points so um and um and the key
observation here is that you know once
you have this uh um um population case
and we have infinite sample case then
because everything is very symmetric um
so because why is a symmetric
distribution around Q so why is a why is
a function that is kind of like
symmetric around q and the initial
distribution is symmetric around Q
because initial distribution is uniform
over the sphere so actually you can show
by induction that the distribution of
the points is always symmetric around Q
so basically the whole Dynamics is
always kind of like about those
symmetric distributions around Q so
basically the kind of the suppose this
is the direction of Q you can see the
the points basically moves in kind of
like Ed way so like it's always
symmetric around q and the only thing
that matters is the movement in a
direction
Q um and U and then actually you can do
this mathematically by proving that
suppos Y is mat around q and and you
project the the U the the neurons or the
particles to the direction of Q and you
cut that W then the loss function is
actually of the form uh of this form
which only depends on the distribution
of w so so the only thing that matters
is the distribution of the projection of
the particles in the in the direction of
of Q and actually this formula is very
similar to it's just a moment matching
thing right so we are basically matching
the the second moment of w to some
scalar gamma 2 and a force M of w to
some scalar gamma four um and that makes
it's much easier to analyze of course
it's still a little bit tricky because
they are still this is still not convex
and so on so forth but right now it's a
onedimensional Dynamics because you need
to care about the onedimensional
Distribution on W so is this we taor
expansion or is this exact this is um
bya um this is exact um um I think the
only Um this can be exact but the the
approximation is not from the T
expansion it's from something like just
I didn't write it precisely so I think
the the exact formul formula would be
something like there's a second term
here inside this as as well which is not
very very important but otherwise is and
and this is using spherical harmonics um
so right but assuming some specific
Sigma did I miss that uh so the C c0 C1
C2 depends on Sigma no yeah oh I see um
yeah sorry question okay okay thanks so
this is basically um um um like spal
harmonics of bullying function you know
it's kind of like a little bit like the
the the the spherical case of the the
function analysis um I I'm not sure
whether this can explain that very well
um so basically the kind of the way to
think about this is that you expand this
you know you expand a square and then
you uh you expand everything in the
spherical harmonic kind ofle uh space
this is my cheat sheet I'm not sure but
it's really useful so so so the way I
think about sper common is that you
start with the one dimensional case you
have this um L polinomial which is which
forms a one dimensional aoral basis and
once you you have this onedimensional
orthonormal basis then you can express
any uh expand every function that is
only a projection to certain direction
into this form so this is a function of
X but it's only the only thing m is in
the direction of U and then you can
expand it because you TR as one
dimensional function you can uh do the
the onedimensional ler expansion and um
and uh and as a result you and also
there's one important thing about the
long polinomial which is actually this
is something similar uh to this is also
true for bullying case as well so so
what's important is that if you have two
uh you take the in part of two functions
like this so both of these two functions
are those kind of basic forms where you
project to One Direction and you apply a
longer polinomial so and you average out
X then the only thing that matter is the
inner product between u and v um and and
also the this two J and K has to match
otherwise is zero um so so in some this
is saying that this this is a uh this
kind of objects are are functions Al
normal functions in the in the high
dimensional space sorry I just missed
something uh do does the distribution of
X matters so what happens if they are on
a cube or something so does it that
matter to be on a sphere the
distribution of X so so to use this all
of these tools in a precise way yes it
does matter um uh so it has to be
uniform over the sphere the distribution
of X has to be uniform over the sphere
see and can you go back to previous
slide so what is this showing that the
movement toward like the direction of Q
so this this as we training or what is
what the animation shows I don't
understand so the animation here shows
that uh I think the animation is more
relevant
to yeah here so this animation shows
that all the points only move um the the
only thing that matters is the direction
q and the the the the distribution of
the point clouds is always spherical
it's always metric around Direction Q so
so that's a that's a um that's kind of
like a a property you can maintain by by
inductive hypothesis by by induction
yeah so is it throughout the training
you right throughout the training if you
have infinite W and infinite
sample thank
you that's why you can reduce this to
one dimensional
case so um anyway so I think I'm gonna
so and then you you use some of these
fers I guess if you do something in the
head so if you expand this you're going
to see a lot of T form things like this
and then you you you get rid of the X
and you only get you and and then you
can rearrange and you get some form um
yeah okay so um and then you can deal
with the one dimensional case and for
the one dimensional case you can compute
the the gradient respect to each of the
particle which is a degree three
polinomial uh and here I'm visualizing
how the particles are moving I guess
let's see whether it's working uh um I
couldn't get a very nice visualization
because I'm I'm like the the pawns don't
move that much so that's
why is it moving yes mov it takes like
two minutes to see anyway let's let's
continue so um so basically the points
are moving gradually according to this
Dynamics right and uh and the kind of
the the first thing we studied when we
studied this Dynamics is that when is
the stationary scenarios right so what
happens when it got stuck so and and
what does mean by getting stuck it means
that all the particles don't move right
as long as one C so actually this is a
beauty of uh of this analyzing this kind
of Dynamics which is a ging um a ging
field of some objective function so once
your Dynamics is is the ging field of
objective function you know that the
only thing that it can get stuck is that
all the particles don't move there's no
way you can have Cycles because as long
as some particle is moving then your
loss function is decreasing because you
have The Descent Lama for ging de set so
so so how much you how much you reduce
the loss function depends on how much
the particle moves and there this
equality so so that's why the only way
that you can get stuck is that all the
particles don't move and that's the
stationary scenario so and basically uh
what happens is that uh eventually uh
what you do is the okay at the end of
the the only the last bullet is what we
wrote in the paper but the the the
thought process is that you first
analyze all the possible stational
points and see when you can get stuck uh
and then and and there and and the bad
thing is that you can indeed get stuck
this is non-convex SCE function so you
can get stuck at a stationary point in
theory um but what happens is that um uh
you uh you will never get close to the
stationing point the stationing points
some of them are not stable and some of
Mar just never get close to them so so
we have a lot of case study maybe like a
total six cases and and you basically
for each of the cases you design some
potential functions to say that you
never get close to the stational point
and if you're far away from the station
points you can prove this kind of like
polyarc uh conditions where you show
that the gradient uh is always
relatively uh big compared to the loss
function so so unless your loss is uh
small you always have good gradient and
and that that means you can decrease
your loss function so um and and that
part is relatively standard um you know
after this as long as you show this and
then the rest of the part is standard so
the hard part is how how do you show you
never get close to station point and Al
how do you even characterize that how do
you characterize the closeness to
station point and and there's no one uh
one thing F out kind of like
characterization for different cases we
have set a different characterization um
and and there are different ways to
prove this for different
cases okay so um yeah so so this so
and the the things I'm I'm hiding here
is is could be a little messy yeah um
okay so that's what uh what we did with
the one dimensional case and um and now
let's talk about the uh the final ways
and final sample case so so how do you
compare the final wte and final sample
case with the infinite wte infinite
sample case so so here's the uh the the
picture for the infinite W and
population case again so you have a lot
of points and they are moving in some
way and uh how do you compare this with
the okay so let's gradually move to
final weight and population loss right
so let's first fin W and and fin samples
so but let's first start with final wdth
and population loss so you still have
infinite number of samples but you only
have a fin number of neurons and that
means that you start with a discrete
distribution maybe just I'm neurons this
blue points are I'm neurons and um and
each of these neurons are moving
according to the same you know a similar
rule as before but not exactly the same
because um because the how does the each
neuron move depends on the distribution
of the neurons and the distribution of
the neurons changes so so each neuron
the rule for each neuron is also a
little bit different but at the end of
day you know each neuron moves you know
and then um you can Define row the T to
be the distribution of this new new set
of neurons at time T and and the the
Dynamics depends on both the particle
and the distribution of the particles
okay so that's what happens with final W
and once you have infinite final W and
empirical loss the only thing that
different is that the loss function is a
little bit different so your gradient is
a little bit different so you have a
little kind of like approximation before
it was like L of real T and now it's l
hat of Y he y hey um is the distribution
of this new uh uh system of of particles
at
time so so basically let me just
um so basically want to move from here
to here and you can see there are a few
type of differences and the way that we
bridge this differences is that you you
start from again the population case and
you first to do uh uh consider
intermediate Dynamics so this
intermediate Dynamics um is um um almost
the same as the uh the population
infinite waste population loss Dynamics
except that you start with um uh this uh
discrete set of neural but note here
that I start with a discrete set of
neurons maybe only just five neurons but
my um my uh my Dynamics is exactly the
same as the Dynamics here I'm not
changing the Dynamics at all I'm only
changing the initialization so that
means that uh so this picture and the
picture before the only difference is
that the new Set uh the this one is just
a subsampling of the previous one
because I didn't change the the Dynamics
um the Dynamics is still computed based
on the population uh uh the the infinite
W neurons right so um so so that's why
this is a very simple case because it's
just a subsampling and you know that
basically you know that the row bar t uh
this distribution is almost the same as
the previous distribution because it's
just a sub samping even though the this
row bar T is very in the was distance is
very far away from the row t uh or in TV
distance robart and R are very different
but um but still if you look at at any
of the functional form like you look at
um integral probability matric right so
any of the functional form as as the the
function is kind of like has restricted
complexity since z bar T is kind of very
close to row
t Okay so this part is um is easy and
then the second part is just that okay
now you look at the final way empirical
loss Dynamics versus the intermediate
one the only difference is that you C
the initialization you say they have the
same initialization and then the only
difference is the dynamic are different
right and theic are different in several
ways one way is that the loss function
is different another way is that the uh
the the the distribution is different
and also once you move once you kind of
like a you are uh like the first step
there you have the same mutualization
right and the Second Step you you
already kind of like um uh the uh the
points are already different right
they're not that same location anymore
so you start to diverge right so your
starting point is even different so
basically The Greening here and Greening
here are comp at different particles so
um so that that contributes to another
source of differences so but you you
basically have a slight um you have
several differences in terms of how the
neurons are moving but they start from
the same set of Blue
Points okay so and then uh how do we
deal with this this is a pretty much
just a a pretty Brute Force kind of like
coupling so you just couple based
onization you just want to say that the
you hat the the real dynamics is uh very
similar to uh this uh UT the the ideal
Dynamics pointwise right for every
possible initialization or maybe in
average over initialization so basically
you're just sping the the UT Kai minus
UT and as I kind of like alluded before
so there are several differences right
so you can expand this differences the
differences in the Dynamics into three
uh um terms and each each term has only
one diff right so here this is the
differences in in terms of the uh the
point you are at this is differences in
terms of the distributions um of the
other neurons and this is the
differences in terms of loss and for the
L functions this about simple complexity
and for the other two is really about
how the Dynamics diverge right because
eventually you know like um eventually
this Dynamics these two Dynamics will
diverge from each other as some point
this because the the arrow becomes
bigger and
bigger so um and the the Temptation is
that you want to get a bond of the form
that the error blows up in some kind of
like way so you say the error is you
know probably smaller than um oh sorry
this is DT so blow ups in some way um
and um it turns out that um this kind of
the first a term and third a term are of
not that very important the main
important term is the second term which
um contributes to exponential blow up so
basically even you your bondus only have
this term beta times U T minus U Square
then you're going to have a exponential
blow up in terms of the error and that
error is you know and the the the
exponential uh the blow up rate is kind
of something about beta and so that's
why the beta will be very important here
so um and um okay so that's the that's
the challenge so basically once you have
exponential blow up it's very subtle
because um um because um if you have the
wrong beta basically suppose your your
estimate for beta uh is U uh is Rong by
a factor of two even by constant Factor
then uh suddenly you grow too fast in
some sense um and um so that's the
that's the hardest part so um so
basically um and and also the
exponential Divergence is also
unavoidable in this case which makes it
even subtle right because you cannot
really get a better rate and the reason
why it's unavoidable is that um if you
look at uh only the second other term um
so basically if you only look at this
term like where you match the second
moment and you can you can see that the
Dynamics for w is going to be something
like um the gamma 2 minus the error in
the second moment times W so this is
kind of like power method especially
when w is small suppose all the W's are
very small then this is just gamma 2 * W
so basically at a very very beginning
with all the W's are very small then you
are basically having a power
method and and the the Divergence of two
uh if you start from different starting
point then you're are going to have a um
basically have a multiplication
gamma two in front of the arrrow so
basically if you start from different
points then the aror just keep blowing
up because it's power method so um um so
so basically what happens is at the
beginning when w is small then you are
having power method you have really
exponential Divergence but uh eventually
the next thing is that eventually you're
going to converge you know the this
moment will match GMA two that's how you
get a loss mod and then at that point
the Divergence speed will slow down so
that's kind of the Savior so you have to
leverage this fact because otherwise you
just keep diverging and there's no way
to control the error of these two
Dynamics so so so this part is um we can
we can do but how do you deal with this
part but how do you control the
exponential Divergence in the beginning
and uh and the way that we fix this is
that we say let's let's do a little more
careful analysis right I I mentioned
that the constant Factor matters and
this is how you can of get the right
constant Factor so you cannot just
really get exactly the right constant
Factor suppose you just use a single
scaler here call it beta then that beta
cannot be the right constant so you make
that constant kind of more dependent on
what where you at so basically what we
do is we say this is the uh uh you you
you say the error kind of like a between
the two Dynamics grows in this way but
also the the the W itself also grows in
this way um so the W becomes bigger and
bigger right as as you can see from this
power method Dynamics so and and it
happens that this these two Factor here
these two scal here are exactly the same
scaler and you work very hard to make
this approximation actually even almost
equality so I think the the exact
constant will be that this is a two here
and this is a four here something like
that so and uh and and then there's some
low out terms which you can ignore and
uh and then you can compare the the two
exponential uh so both of these two uh
two two kind of like um uh um recursion
kind of blows up you know expans fast
but they blows up exactly at the same
rate uh you know exactly the Conant in
front of them so I see comparatively but
you don't know exactly what this
quantity is but you know this one you
know kind of like blows up you know by
by exactly a factor of two faster than
this one in some sense so and uh and
this Dynamics you know never can never
blow up blow blows up like
a forever because the W has a upper Bond
like you can you cannot just the W
cannot go go to Infinity right so w is
kind of like between minus one and one
and then that's how you control how long
this this one will blow up and that and
then you use the that bond to inform the
the other bond to show how the other
bonds kind of flows up um yeah so that's
the that's the technical part of this um
but I think the the the real the so I I
I can imagine there many maybe there are
many other uh cleaner analysis for this
uh uh eventually if we work harder on
this um but the point here is that I
think the the real um the real kind of
like a click clicking moment for for us
is that we realize that exponential
Divergence is not avoidable and it's not
avoidable only because initially you
have a power method uh and that's the
only reason why it's not avoidable and
and and after that I think you know it's
just just a matter of time to figure out
what's the right analysis to to leverage
fact um I think I'm I'm oh I'm a little
bit early okay that's that's good okay
so yeah just a quick summary so we have
this mean field analysis for qu Target
functions with um um unmodified SGD with
polom weights and iterations and the
technical invation is that first you
leverage Symmetry and spherical
harmonics to reduce the population
Dynamics to 1D problem and then you
analyze the population Dynamics with
details this is not very easy I didn't
talk too much about it but this this is
a little messy and then you have a
tighter balance to couple the arrow
between the uh uh between the the
population dynamic and the final way
final sample Dynamics and the key
Innovation there is that you have a
tighter bond by comparing the signal
with the uh the growth of w with the the
growth of the W That's What I Call
signal with the the growth of the
arror um and I think there are probably
a list of open questions you know to see
how does this um technique uh uh uh
extend to more complex settings so one
of the possibilities you can generate
through Ru um and uh at least the for
for the one dimensional case the the SP
harmonic still works for reu it's just
they have like a longer expansion um but
the Dynamics will be complicated when
you have like a higher degree terms uh
the sample complexity we don't really
believe that D2 3.1 is the best one um
so um but that's probably is because we
didn't do a concentration in quality in
the best way it already takes like 15
pages to do the concentration
inequalities with all the uh um the
items that kind of with some of this um
uh concentration papers um um and so
that's why we didn't work harder on that
um and you can also have the M index
model and you can also try to deal with
OP optimizing both of the the first
layer and second layer um yeah I guess
that's all I want to say
thanks any more questions for than
you so in the proof outline you went
from so you did a finite number of
neurons and um finite samples um but you
haven't yet got into uh finite you
optimization steps so it's still a a
continuous time gradient flow um in your
in the paper do you do gradient descent
and if so was there were there any uh
technical difficulties in going from
continuous to discreet time yeah so the
uh the disc we in the paper we do have
analysis for discret time um where you
use like a inverse polinomial small um
so and there's no any additional
challenge there because this is actually
what we added after we have the first
version this is the second version so uh
the reason that is not a problem is
because uh typically the the challenge
to discretize is that you your error can
like the the again it's another
approximation right the discrete time
algorithm versus The Continuous time
algorithm and and this these two
Dynamics might kind of flag diverge
right and you just reuse the same kind
of flag analysis to show they don't
diverge as as fast as you
like they don't diverge very fast yeah
so so it's the same analysis pretty much
I see but so in addition you would also
need that in the continuous time it
wouldn't take exponentially long in
continuous time to get to the like a
desired solution so is the not you know
fast convergence in time is that
achieved with the like the pl condition
that you uh you referenced yeah yeah so
that's a that's a great question so so
um so for this for the for the initial
phase I because you compare with the
growth of the signal you don't really
care about how long it takes because
even if it takes a long time um um
because because this quantity never
blows up so so so by comparison like
your your your error that doesn't grow
up doesn't doesn't kind of like blow up
that much um but in some of the later
stage we did have to have absolute Bond
on how the how much the error grows uh
at every iteration or for every unit of
time so uh and for those cases you do
need a absolute Bond on how long you run
the algorithm so that's why um here I
didn't I I I was kind of like I sweep
this and The Rock so I only say little
of one um so because we uh the analysis
can only work until it reach a little of
one error it doesn't work for every
Epsilon so if absum is like one over D
to the square then uh the Anis doesn't
work anymore so that could be an open
question as well like how do you analyze
that final uh um like if you run it for
long enough I think if you run it for
long enough this this should still like
a everything should still work
fundamentally just like you need a
little bit different analysis to show
how um to kind of like to a more kind of
careful analysis to bounce the how does
the error growth
eventually one last question so a 3.1 is
not a very round number do is there like
a simple explanation as to why you have
a have 3.1 as the exponent yeah I think
it's a d to the three times uh anything
that is super uh super polog maybe super
um so basically it's the D2 three point
uh three plus anything any constant but
it cannot be D to the poly log I think
sorry it cannot be D to the three times
the poly log d That's not big enough uh
yeah something like that thank
you I guess do you mind sketching some
intuition where the DQ bottle comes from
like if it's degree T polinomial should
I just think it is like T minus one
plus I think there's a I I don't know
like the the sample complex analysis is
very complicated because because what
happens is that you need to bound let's
see so basically you need to bound the
differences between L hat and L right so
that's how the simple complexity uh is
done and L and also actually you B NAA L
head versus NAA L and what is na L and
NAA l so that's where I think I had this
somewhere very
briefly uh y so this this is the l l
right and L head will be to use
empirical samples instead of the
expectation and because this L is a so
this is na L right because na L is kind
of like a complicated object so you have
a degree three this Sigma Prime is
degree three and and you have another X
so it's a degree four polinomial and you
have this which is degree four so
basically you are bonding a degree AG so
basically you are doing the
concentration of a degree Ag polinomial
and you have to do uniform convergence
uh actually this there's a Lotty there
like you canot do uniform convergence
over the entire space you have to
uniform convergence over uh over a tube
around the trajectories you may possibly
like so basically there's a trajectory
for the population Dynamics and you
build a tube around the TR trajectory
and say you never leave that your
Dynamic control that you never leave
that tube and and for that tube you do
uniform convergence so basically you
have a uniform convergence for eight
degree polinomial over kind of like a
Cube so um uh and and that requires U um
so so we are using some of this um
papers by items like I tell that bounce
this um things like u u like bound the
concentration of U transpose x to the
power P right and you read that many
times and and I think in that we know
some part of those analysis is very
tight but some other parts is not tight
so so so that's why we don't know where
we
lose
any other
questions all right cting thank you
again
[Applause]
excent and now we have a break until 3
3M